today's guest speaker is Emmett Scheer
Emmett is the CEO of twitch which was
acquired by Amazon where he now works
and Emmett is going to do a new format
of class today and talk about how to do
great user interviews so this is the
talking to users part of starting to
startup should be really useful thank
you very much for coming contact server
knows where I'm coming from
from this we started her by stirred my
first startup with justin khan right out
of college we started this company
called keiko calendar it didn't go so
well
when I went alright we built it we we
sold it but we sold it on eBay so that's
not necessarily at the end you want for
your startup and it was a it was a good
time we learned a lot we learned a lot
about programming we didn't know
anything about calendars neither of us
were users of calendars nor did we
during the period of time we worked on
Kiko talk to anyone who actually did use
a calendar so that was that was not
optimal
we got the build stuff part of the
startup down we did not get the talk to
users part the second startup we started
we used a very common trick that lets
you get away with not talking to users
which was that we were our own consumer
we we had this idea for a television
show justin.tv a reality show about
Justin Khan's life and we built a whole
set of Technology and website around the
reality show we wanted to run and so we
were the user for that for that product
and that's actually one way to cheat and
get away with not talking to many other
users is if you're just building
something that literally is just for you
you don't need to talk to anyone else
because you know what it is you want and
what you need but that's if you're
really limiting way to start a startup
most startups are not just built for the
person who is uh who is using them and
when you do that every now and then you
get really lucky and you are
representative of some huge class of
people who all want the exact same thing
you do but very often also that just
turns into a side project that doesn't
go anywhere so we kept working on
justin.tv for a while and we actually
achieved a good deal of success because
it turned out that there were people out
there who wanted to do the same thing we
did which was broadcast ourselves live
on the Internet but
the issue with justin.tv the thing that
the thing that sort of kept us from
achieving greatness is we hadn't figured
out yet how to how to build towards
anything beyond that initial TV show we
knew how to build a great product
actually if you wanted to run a live
24/7 reality television show about your
life we had the website for you we had
exactly what you needed but if we wanted
to go do more than that who had to open
it up to a broader spectrum of people a
broader spectrum of use cases we didn't
have we didn't have the insight to
figure that out because we weren't that
user and so at some point we decided to
pivot justin.tv we decided we needed to
go in a new direction
we thought we'd built a lot of valuable
technology but we hadn't identified the
use case that would let it get really
big and there are two directions that
seem promising one of them was mobile
and one of them was gaming and I led the
gaming initiative inside of the company
and what we did with gaming that was
very very different from what we'd ever
done before was we actually went and
talked to users because well I loved
watching gaming video I was very aware
that neither I nor anyone else in the
company knew anything about broadcasting
video games and so I was an throughout
the content I thought there was a market
there that was sort of the insight that
did I had that I think wasn't common at
the time which is how much fun it was to
watch video games quick show of hands
people know about watching video games
in the internet here ok I'm going to
assume the people listening to this also
know about it if you don't know about
watching video games the internet you
should go read about that because it
sort of important context for the stuff
I'm going to talk about but the main
point is I thought that was awesome
but I didn't know anything about the
side of it that was really important
which is actually acquiring the content
to start broadcasting so we went out and
we ran a actually a very large number of
user interviews we talked to a lot of
people and brought that data back and
that formed the core of all the decision
making that was for the next three years
of product features on Twitch was sort
of the insights we got from that and we
continued to talk to users and in fact
built an entire part of the company
whose job it is basically to talk to our
users which is a whole division that we
just didn't even have it just
TV we had no one at the company whose
job it was to talk to our most important
users so so that was twitch and I'm
gonna I want to give you guys a little
bit of a a little bit of an insight into
with twitch what what that what that
meant going to go talk to users so we
determined that the broadcaster's are
the most important people and the reason
we determined that was when we went and
looked into the market Weiland
we looked into what what determined why
people watched a certain streamer NART
went to a certain website they would
just follow the content right you had a
you had a piece of content you loved and
the broadcaster would come with you and
that's actually the one really important
point about user interviews which is
that who you talk to is as important as
what questions you ask them what you
pull away from it because if you go and
talk to a set of users if we'd gone to
talk to viewers only would have gotten a
completely different set of feedback
than talking to the broadcaster's and
talking to the broadcaster's gave us
insight into how to build something for
them that turned out to be strategically
correct I wish I could tell you the
recipe for figuring out who the target
user is for your product and who your
target user should be but there isn't a
recipe it comes down to think really
hard and use your user judgment to
figure out who you're really building
this for so what I want to do is a
little bit something a little bit
interactive now which is we're gonna I
got a bunch of ideas from from you guys
actually so sort of suggested ideas and
I'm gonna pick one of them and I want
everyone to sort of sit down and do do
step one of this process for me right
now which is think about who would you
go ask about this like which people
where would you go to find the people
you needed to talk to about this in
order to in order to learn about what
you should build and so the idea we're
gonna use is let me see here
of these ideas so here it's a lecture
focus note-taking app the idea is I
don't think that the state of the art
for note-taking is good enough yet and I
want to make a note-taking app that in
you know improves that experience makes
taking notes in class better or taking
notes while listening to a lecture
online better so you know maybe it has
collaboration
features maybe it like helps you focus
better somehow it has multimedia
enhancements on and out right all sorts
of possible features but that's the
that's the idea so take like take 120
seconds right now and think about not
what you would ask or what the right
features for this app is but who would
you talk to who should the who's gonna
give you that feedback that's gonna tell
you whether this is good or not I
actually mean it right now take your
laptop out like type write some stuff
down think think about like the you can
it's it's good enough to like think of
that in your head but actually like if
you actually just write it down and like
just come up with the five people you
talk to or the five types of people you
talk to and who you think the most
important one was like actually do it
because there's nothing like actually
running through a practice of something
and trying to do it to actually get it
into your head
the right way to do it I'm gratified to
hear clicking and of keyboards now if
you're following along at home pause
actually do it think about who would you
talk to because that's a that is the
first question for almost any startup
that you need to answer is like who is
my user and and where am I going to find
them
all right that's like way shorter than
you'd normally used to think about this
problem it's actually a really tricky
problem and like figuring out where to
source the people is pretty hard but uh
we're going to move along anyways and
the in this highly abbreviated version
of learning how to build a product and
run a user interview so can I can I can
I get one volunteer from the audience to
come up and we'll talk about it you guys
are here we go and so you talk to a
bunch of college students would you pick
any particular subset of college
students like sounds like you want to
talk to all college students or like a
broader I went on to talk to college
students on like I'm break down the
divisions by like people who study
different areas maybe and then also
maybe what makes sense for people who
have like different study techniques
because some people take a lot of notes
some people don't take that many notes
but still John stuff down great so I
mean that that's really good start like
that's that is actually obviously group
of users you want to go talk to you
especially if you're targeting something
at you know at college students as the
consumer and if you're talking to
college students as a consumer the
you're gonna get a lot out of students
about what their current note-taking
habits are and you know what they would
be excited about one of the problems
with selling things to college students
is that college students don't actually
spend very much money it's it's really
hard to get you guys to open your
wallets especially if you want them to
pay for a school related thing I mean
people don't even want to buy textbooks
right
you probably probably all use Chegg or
that you know borrow it from your friend
or whatever and so one of the like one
of the things with that you'd be missing
if you go after just the students right
is you want to figure out who who is the
most important person to this to this
abbot if you actually add a note taking
app my guess is for colleges the people
most likely to actually buy and
note-taking app that you guys would use
would be college IT right I mean
presumably for most for the most part is
going to sell software to students like
the people who have to get bought into
that is usually the school administrator
so that would mean up that we want
approach you feel I thought okay well
you presumably go talk to the college
students and you find out they don't
actually buy any note-taking software
right now at all I mean likely it's
possible they do in which case I'm I'm
really wrong this is why you have to go
talk to the users but you then have to
try to maybe try other other air groups
right so I would talk to college I talk
to IT administrators as well I think
that's a that's another area it's really
promising you might talk to parents
right who spends money on their kids
education it's like willing to pull
their wallet out like the you know
parents of kids parents get to a
freshman or going off to college for the
first time you need this app to make
your kid productive so that they don't
fail out of college and and there's
actually a lot of groups that are
potential but aren't necessarily the
obvious user but who are critical
critical to your app success potentially
and you when you're when you're start at
the very beginning of a start-up like
this when you're like you have this idea
that you think is awesome you want to
have that broadest group you possibly
can you don't just want to talk to one
type of person and and learn that you
want to get familiar with the space when
you get familiar with the various kinds
of people who'd be contributing all
right so let's let's have someone come
up and we're gonna pretend we're going
to run this user interview so we're
gonna talk to a college student and try
to find out what we should build you
know what we should get into this
note-taking app so so some another
volunteer place for running an interview
yes
all right so hello hi I'm Stephanie hi
Stephanie welcome thank you for agreeing
to do this user interview with us
so I wanted to hear from you about you
know what are your note-taking habits
like how do you take notes today sure so
I take notes in a variety of ways I like
to now because speed and efficiency just
to come back to it later it's easy for
me to just take notes on my laptop and
so a lot of those notes will be
primarily text-based
but in certain classes so for example if
I'm taking a history class most of it
will be in text but if I'm taking it
taking a physics class for example
they're gonna be more complex diagrams
different angles that I have to draw and
so that's a little harder harder for me
to get what software do you use for this
stuff today I just do pen and paper for
that you dependent paper so you do a
combination you take notes with pen and
paper you take that to the computer
sometimes yeah and when you take notes
with when you take all these notes at
the end but do you actually review them
like you be honest do you actually go
back and ever actually look at these
notes the pen and paper not so much but
yes to the software-based because it's
more easy to access and it's easier for
me to share and collaborate and maybe
like even merge notes with classmates
and friends so what do you what do you
stick notes today on your computer
Google Docs and Evernote Google Docs and
Evernote and tell me more about like why
two things at the same time um so
Evernote is easy if I'm trying to just
collect it for myself I think and yes
you can sure but I think Google Docs for
me is easier to share and it depends
also if you know a friend is already
created a folder for example a guru ox
and I just have to add to that folder if
it's a group project for example versus
if it's for my personal use I tend to
get more to it so it sounds like you a
lot of like note-taking collaboration
yeah what uh tell me more about that
like like do you take us do you wind up
taking most of the notes most the value
of the notes out of notes other people
take or is it mostly your owner it's
your view at the end of the semester how
does that work it's mostly mine because
I'm pretty picky about the way I like
things organized like design-wise or
formatting and even color I'm really
particular with and like the font that
we use and that really affects the way I
study so I tend to like it to like to
like
personalize it even after I merge so you
you pulling know some other people but
then you merge them into into the
mailing works for me right awesome and
if you if you have Evernote notes and
you have Google Docs notes and you have
a pen and paper notes once the semester
is over you ever go back to any of that
stuff where is it like recorder you guys
aren't quarters here right
once the quarter is over you ever go
back to any of that stuff you ever for
classes not so much but if it's notes
that I've taken for like talks like
these for example or if it's like
interview prep that I'm doing I tend to
go back because it's things that I like
to kind of keep fresh in my mind and to
help me prep for future things that's
interesting tell me more about that like
you take notes not just in class yeah so
I take notes to also just summarize main
points so if it's like inspirational
quotes for example from talks that I go
to like these and then like maybe I'm
going to an event where I'm actually
going to meet someone and it helps to
actually to think about and to remember
and recall what was shared at the time
that you know I attended the talk or
something awesome
all right well normally I'd actually dig
into a lot more detail there's a huge
amount of like open questions that are
still in my mind after hearing that
stuff questions about which people do
you collaborate with questions about
whether or not you like like what the
volume of notes are and like how how
long of note-taking stuff in just sort
of digging into like what the current
behavior is but like in the interest of
time and not like keeping everyone here
hearing about the intricacies of one
person is note-taking habits forever
we're gonna move on but thank you very
much definitely appreciate that so so
that that's like that kind of stuff you
notice we're not talking about the
actual contents of the app at all like
I'm not I'm not really interested in
features I don't really want to know
about what they the specific feature set
in Google Docs or Evernote I might start
digging in a little bit more into which
features actually get used like if she's
actively collaborating you know is how
does that work I heard some interesting
things about oh yet we use folders
that's interesting to me but the main
thing you're trying to do when you're
running these first set of interviews is
not necessarily get like questions about
like user flows and like optimizing that
or questions about
like the specifics of of any of that
stuff kind of can be distracting because
users think they know what they want but
like you you get the you get the
horseless carriage effect where you're
you're you're getting asked for a faster
horse instead of trying to design the
actual real solution to the problem if
you start asking people about features
so you want to stay as far away from
Peters as possible because the things
they tell you wind up almost feeling
overwhelmingly real when you have a real
user asking you for a feature it's very
hard to say no to them
because here's a real person who really
has this problem and they they're saying
build me this feature but as you start
to talk to lots of people and really get
a sense for what what their problems are
you figure out if this is actually
promising your air or not and like based
on what I heard there it's like starting
from that easier interview I'm not
necessarily positive there is a problem
or there's at least there's a there's a
big enough problem that it's worth
building a whole new product for because
I didn't hear a lot of like things where
I'm where there was a big blocker where
there's something really wrong with the
way it the way it it was working and
unless I had some big idea I would take
that as a you know maybe a negative sign
but it doesn't necessarily mean that you
can't you can't move forward and keep
talking to more people because just
because you're the first person you
don't get anything out of it doesn't
mean there's not going to be a ton more
people who actually have a problem and
you once you've talked to you about 6 7
8 people you're usually about done it's
unlikely you're gonna discover a bunch
of new information there which is why
it's important to talk to different
extremes of people right go find people
who are at different different points
because if you doctors just six or seven
Stanford college students you're going
to get a very different response that
need we talk to six or seven high school
students or 6 to 7 6 7 parents all right
what's gonna look at the so based on
that though right I think the I think
it's possible you could come up with a
set of ideas right you have this
information about how someone takes
notes you've you've come up with
potentially when you came up with study
you had you had some ID
you heard this idea you had some ideas
it's like how you could build something
cool and so if you're gonna build just
one feature on top of Google Docs what
would that feature be right and that's
for a new product this that might be a
good way to like get started thinking
about where to go which is okay so
they're extensively using this thing
right now how can we make that
experience just one quantum better
something that would be really exciting
to this person to be one one step ahead
and so don't you take two minutes right
now and think about what that feature
might be actually like try to try to
come up with what what you might do
based on what you heard from from
Stephanie that could convince her to
switch away from her current
collaborative multi-person all working
together workflow on Google Docs to your
new your new thing that is has all the
features of Google Docs plus this one
special thing that's like going to make
it
that's gonna make it more bit more
useful and convince them to stop using
the thing they're already using
awesome alright so I'm gonna invite our
third guest if you if you have something
up I don't want to put you on the spot
if you feel like you don't you're not
sure but uh yeah what is it on yeah okay
what I thought about was like the the
reason she uses ever no is because like
of like sticky note type notes like like
more thoughts and like details so I feel
like Google Docs has like documents and
not like smaller notes so I feel like a
feature that would be like super like
I'm a mobile version of Drive that
doesn't like isn't that clunky and like
doesn't make you make real documents
could be like really useful awesome
all right that's a that's a good insight
right that's exactly what's one of the
things you'd get out of that user
interview and now you have this idea
right you've gotten this this user fit
feedback you got this idea what if we
had a Google Docs that had the
collaborative aspects and the group
aspects of that but where are you you
could pull in more little one-off notes
and it was it was designed more around
note-taking and so the question is now
once you have this idea which I think
it's that it's a vacuum perfectly
reasonable approach is this enough
is this something people would actually
switch just to have and the way to
validate there's two ways to validate
that one is if you're a cricket
programmer you can literally just go
build it and throw it out in the world
and see what happens and that's a that's
great and if that mean that works that's
a that's an excellent way to approach it
but a lot of the time that one little
thing that's just a little bit better
might take you three months to actually
build something that's worthy of
actually using and so you actually want
to go out and validate that idea further
before you go ahead and start building
it and so you might take that idea you
might go back go back out and you know
you can sit down with with diagrams you
can you can draw what the what it looks
like draw the workflow and go bring that
in front of people but the one thing you
really don't want to do is ask them this
is this is just a sort of a trap I want
to warn you against doing is just don't
go out and
say to come for the future idea and go
out and ask people are you I got this
idea for a future are you excited about
it because the the feedback you get from
users if you tell them about a future
and ask them is this feature good is
often oh yeah that's great like that
sounds like such a good idea but when
you actually take that in front of
people and you actually build it you
then find out that well they thought it
was such a clever idea no one actually
like cares the switch to get it and so
the one question you can't ask is is
this feature actually good or not yes
yeah so Sam's asking you what's the
what's the minimum you can actually get
away with to validate given that you
can't actually just go and ask them is
this good or not and it's it's highly
dependent the answer that's highly
dependent on the particular feature but
usually the the best thing you can do is
is really just hack something together
right it's you find if you're if your
idea is to build something on top of
Google Docs don't for your v1 go rebuild
awesome Google Documents but for
notetaking application find a way to
write a browser extension that that that
stuff's just that little bit of
incremental feature in and and see if
it's actually useful for people go like
actually go find a way to cheat is what
it comes down to it because if you can't
actually put it in front of people it's
really really hard to to find that out
for bigger things we're actually trying
to get people to spend money it actually
gets a lot easier so if you're selling
it it's great actually sales is this
cure-all for this problem get people to
put give you their credit card and I
guarantee you they're actually
interested in the future
it's one of the most valid anything's
you can do for a product is go out there
and actually get them to commit to pay
you up front and the problem is when
you're working on a student note-taking
app that's gonna be relatively hard
because you probably unless your ideas
that you're actually going to sell it
it's probably something where you're
thinking at least the trial version is
free and you're not necessary gonna
learn that much by trying to charge
people money but if you go out there and
you if you can get people to say hey I'm
gonna I'm gonna give you money the money
test is amazing it really does clarify
whether or not
they're really excited about it or not
because if you're not $5 excited about
it you're probably not very excited
about it
so the last thing I wanted to do is
actually work through with you guys what
happened to twitch so I brought some
slides of feedback um that I'd like to
get put up
that's my only slides for the UH for the
thing and it's it's what it is it's it's
it's representative excerpts of twitch
feedback I had a whole like 26 page
document full of all the feedback and
then I realized that reading that was
going to be a little bit tedious and
there was no way I'd make it through it
in a lecture so pretend that like this
is stuff is all representative of like
lots of people said this kind of thing
out to to us when we ask them questions
and I've already pre condensed it for
you into the real feedback you got so
when we were working on twitch to go
launch it we wouldn't we talked too much
of existing justin.tv broadcasters and
asked them about their experience
broadcasting what they liked about
broadcasting why they broadcasted what
they broadcasted what else was going on
in their life and the interesting thing
is when you talk to users of your
product or detail users of your product
they come back to you with actually very
detail things about features because
they actually get mired in the feature
and you've sort of read between the
lines but they asked to profess things
like I want to be way to clear the
banned list in my chat room like this
that was actually very common requests
because there was a particular issue
with how our chat rooms worked
people would ask for the ability to edit
the titles of highlights after creating
them and and it's it's the this was like
this stuff was really consistent as you
talk to broadcasters you probably talked
to 12 14 so they like that broadcaster
so the justin.tv gaming platform we got
we got all this feedback and you know
what else we have we have your
competitors have all these cool features
like polls and scrolling tags you can
personalize chat there and then we have
some positive feedback they're like oh
you guys don't have ads that's great
I didn't hear the band trolls so much
yourself about chat a bunch of stuff
around interactivity with with
interactivity with the with their
viewers and that was all really
interesting right so this is what this
is what the Justin TV broadcasters
wanted us to build and this is what they
with
where they felt pain using the using the
product and so if you thought that what
we did was go and address these problems
you would be wrong because actually
people who are using your service
already and are willing to put up with
all these issues kind of kind of means
that these are probably not actually the
biggest problems because if you're
willing to ignore the fact that you
can't edit the band lists and titles are
uneditable and there's no way to get
rolls out of your channel and you're
using the service anyways maybe those
aren't huge problems and so that sort of
brings up another really important point
which is you have to compare you think
it to compare groups of people and
compare the level which they they argue
each other so if you go to the next
slide yes nice
we got competitor broadcaster feedback
which is really interesting so this is
stuff that you could we heard a lot from
people who are using other broadcast
platforms they wanted to be able to
switch multiple people onto their
channel at the same time they they
complained about us not having a rev
share program or they talked a lot about
how they were trying to make a living
they really wanted to make money
pursuing this pursuing this gaming
broadcasting thing they talked about a
lot about video stability our service
wasn't good in Europe specifically but
but just globally video stability was
this huge huge issue for them and if you
compare and contrast actually it was
really different like the things that
people who didn't use our service said
about what they cared about was
completely different than the things
that people who are using the service
cared about and we focused on this stuff
because this was a software it was so
bad they weren't even willing to use our
service because of it
and most of them actually had thought
about it because we were our user base
what happened to be a very well-educated
user base in this in the area who knew
about all their options for this and
they would they actually you know
reaching out to them meant that they
they'd probably tried all four services
it actually had an opinion it's great
when you can get users who are that that
informed then that that they understand
the space that well and if you go out of
the I'm just going to go to the next
slide yeah here we go
the other big thing we did that that was
really important was we talked to non
broadcasters so we went out there and we
talked to all the people who weren't
using
or competitors and in many ways those
are the most important people right
talking your competitors that's a
short-term win right someone's using a
competing piece of computing software
unless your your piece of competing
software or something like Google which
is a search engine which everyone uses
okay maybe then then there are no non
users to convert but in the case of
gaming broadcasting almost everyone's a
non user right the majority and this is
true for most new products the majority
of people you're competing with are non
users they're people who have never used
your service before and what they say is
actually the most important what they
say is is the thing that blocks you from
expanding from expending the size of the
market with your features right if you
all you do is look at your competitors
and yourself and all you do is talk to
your computer you know people who use
your competitors products people use
your products you can never expand try
not never but you're not learning the
things that help you expand the size of
the market you want to talk to the
people who aren't even trying to use one
of these things yet who've thought about
it maybe but who aren't corn into it so
what did they say my computer isn't fast
enough I'm focused on training 12 hours
a day for the next tournament
I like making the perfect video and like
editing it and so I just upload things
to YouTube I don't do live streaming I
don't I I have no desire to go into that
space or this is actually particularly
in Korea this is a big problem once our
strategy gets broadcast in a major
tournament we have to start over we have
to like come up with an entirely new
strategy and so the last thing we ever
do want to do would be broadcast our
practice sessions are you crazy
that's gonna hurt us in the next big
tournament and so this became this
became a big outreach program for us
trying to figure out how we can get
people over this we bought people
computers we we worked really closely
with gaming broadcast software companies
to help the who made the broadcasting
software to make that better we started
building broadcasting into games and
into platforms like we built
broadcasting into the Xbox we built
broadcasting the PlayStation 4 because
we wanted need to overcome this issue
that like it was too hard
broadcasting wasn't uh wasn't possible
and so you sort of combine these
Frosty's were the three big groups we
looked at for broadcasting and you
combine that feedback and what it tells
you is not the features to build right
because they the features they asked for
things like polls
things like a you know the the ability
to have a child account like child
accounts on your account we haven't
built most of that stuff but what was
important where were the where the the
issues like the goals they were trying
to accomplish there people wanted money
people wanted stability in quality
people wanted universal access for
viewers all around the world to be able
to watch them and so that became our
focus actually and we dumped almost all
of our resources into things that none
of that no one ever mentioned in an
interview but those are the things that
actually address the problem and the way
you could tell that it worked is we we
would build these things then we'd go
back to this exact same people we
interviewed and we'd say hey you told us
you really cared a lot about making
money well we've got you the
subscription program that will let you
make money and it it's it's astonishing
because most people aren't have never
had that experience actually they've
never talked to someone and said it
would really great if your product had
feature X and then and then like two
months later or a month later your
product actually has feature X or at the
very least a feature that addresses the
problem they brought up and so it was
actually the the people we converted
first to our product were the people
that we'd talk to about user research
they were the ones who were actually the
most impressed which is kind of fun but
it really works because we pick people
who are representative and we picked big
broadcasters small ones medium ones and
we we made sure we were addressing their
concerns and that that was completely
different from how we'd approach the
problem on justin.tv because in
justin.tv when we try to do this we we
sat down we trawl through huge amounts
of data like we we spent tons of time
looking at google analytics looking at
Mixpanel looking at in-house analytics
tools figuring out how people use the
service looking at where our traffic
came from completion rates on flows we
spent all this time doing that and that
that's good I mean you can learn things
from that I'm not telling you not to
look at your at your data but it doesn't
tell you where you need to go it doesn't
tell you where what the problems are you
need to address and so we would just
sort of invent these ideas and justin.tv
and then nine times out of ten without
talking to someone that idea turns out
to be bad and that's one of the most
disappointing things about doing user
interviews and user feedback which is
why I think so many people don't do it
we
that you're gonna get negative in news
about your your favorite pet feature
most of the time like you have this
great idea and you're gonna talk to a
user and it's gonna turn out that uh
that nobody actually wants that like no
no one's actually they're actually
completely concerned about completely
different things and they don't care
about what you thought was important at
all and and that's a little bit sad but
just just think about how sad you'd be
in four months when you launched that
feature and it turns out no one actually
wants to use it so I think that's about
it for my the lecture section of what
we're talking about I want take some
questions from from the audience that's
the most common mistakes are showing
people your product don't don't show
them your product it's it's sort of like
telling them about a feature you want to
learn about what's already in their
heads your you want to avoid putting
things there the other thing is uh
asking about your your pet feature
direction so if you think you want to
add subscriptions to your product going
and asking people would you pay for a
subscription going and asking them would
you use this feature and I'd say the the
other big mistake people make is talking
to who's available rather than talking
to who they need to talk to there's
certain users that are really easy to
get at because they are say members of
your forum already right you have a you
have some product forum and you go and
you talk to the users on that forum
because they're they're easy to get
access to we spent like weeks digging
for identity information and figuring
out who these people were so we could
contact them so we could talk to them
because a lot of these people weren't it
wasn't obvious they were just some user
on a on a site and that site didn't
support messaging there was like no
obvious way to interact with them and so
we spent a bunch of time trying to
network and find those users and bring
them on because if you if you just talk
to who's easy to talk to you're not
really getting getting the best data the
the fortunate side there is that almost
everyone is flattered to be asked what
they think and so most of them will
actually talk to you and tell you things
yeah how hard was it to get buy-in from
the rest of your company I mean like you
can go and be like whatever on in charge
so you're doing what I say but it's
probably not the best wait a minute so
how did you get it
that's a good question so the the
question is uh how hard is it to get
buy-in from the rest of the company and
how do you do it um getting buy-in if
you just go to them and say I figured I
talked to the users I figured it out we
have to build this it's really hard um
because people don't trust you there's
something magic about showing them the
interview though so I really recommend
you record interviews recording
interviews it's like magic eh it stops
you from taking notes in the middle and
taking notes is a little bit disruptive
it makes it hard for you to feel like
you're actually engaged in the
conversation and be you can then play
that recording for people so in they
don't have to be there for the entirety
of all the interviews but when you want
to make a point about what what what we
should be building and why you can just
play back for the rest of the company
that interview and it's like magic the
influence it has on people's thoughts
and what's what the right thing the
build is yes so you definitely want to
do Skype or sorry the question was to be
insist on Skype interviews for recording
you don't want to do interviews over
email if you can avoid it because
interviews over email are not
interactive and the most interesting
things you learn in interview is come
from the interesting tell me more
because the incident that you hit you
hope this vein you know they'll say
something you didn't expect and the
instant they say something you didn't
expect or didn't already know you should
drop into the Detective Mode and
Detective Mode is huh that's interesting
can you tell me more about that how many
people don't like silence so they'll
keep talking to fill the void and the
best part about doing it over Skype or
doing it in person is you have that
interactive feedback and you can
actually pull a lot more out of people
email interviews are they're okay but
they're they're basically useless if
you're in person or over Skype they're
actually also easy to record make sure
you ask them if it's okay to record it
it's not polite to record people without
their consent but if they're willing to
like give you an user interview they're
probably willing for you to record it as
well
[Music]
yeah
so the question is like what about
people in the international market we're
trying to do user interviews with you
who don't speak your language that's
just really hard and actually to this
day twitch works way better in
english-speaking countries than it does
in non-english speaking countries and I
think a big part of that is we are much
better at talking to people in
english-speaking countries and learning
what their needs are and we're not as
good at it in other countries we've
tried to address that by hiring people
who speak Korean having them translate
we tried to address that by finding
representative people in those countries
who speak both English in Korean and
reaching out to them but the problem
with that is like the you're not
actually getting a representative sample
no matter how hard you try the very fact
that they are a fluent English speaker
means they're not representative of all
the people who don't speak fluent
English it's just a hard problem it's
why companies find it easier to build
markets that win in their home in their
home country much more easily than
abroad because it's really hard to talk
to users abroad yes
so the channels we use to what channels
we used to reach out to and when do we
ever compensate them the channels we
used to reach out to them were on-site
messaging systems so like if you're most
site websites have somewhere to contact
the user so they're a visible user of
another website you use that sites
messaging system and say hey I was
watching your stream or whatever this
person was doing on the site I'd love to
ask you some questions about your use
would you mind hopping on a Skype call
and as for the other thing we do is we
find out who peoples were me to send
them email we'd like run into them at
events because a lot of these people go
to the same events and we like would go
to the events and like get we wouldn't
run the user interview at the event but
you get to know them you exchange
business cards or you know whatever it
is you actually do now that aren't isn't
business cards and and you get in touch
with them we tended not to compensate
people I think that if you if know if
people don't care enough about the
problem to like talk to someone who's
trying to solve it you probably barking
up the wrong tree we never had any
trouble getting people to talk to us
about paying
so so this is a whole second set of user
feedback that's really important that
actually talked about the question was
what about like on-site user feedback
tools and I think the stuff you're
talking about is where you you have like
a a new product and you want to see how
if it's actually gonna work or not and
so you put it in front of people and you
see how they use it or not that's really
important that kind of work is super
super important it can tell you lots of
things about where you went wrong
building something before you launch it
which is great it doesn't tell you what
to build it helps you iron out the kinks
and edges of the thing you did build but
generally speaking we that wasn't the
kind of user feedback we were getting I
mean if that stuff's good it's good it's
like it's much more similar though to
the the data driven approach right
you're finding out why are people
dropping off in this flow you're not
finding out what problem should I really
be solving for them and what what do
they care about as a human and for this
kind of like really early says user
interview which is the kind of user
interview that's crucial startups do
that's the that's where you want to
focus so we didn't bring anyone on site
actually I was almost all over phone or
Skype yes yeah so with three different
kinds of people did we focus on one of
them given that we had very limited
resources yes we focused on the
competing people using competing
products because we knew that they
already were interested in the behavior
that we needed and they were willing to
do it at all and therefore all we had to
do is give it some of the switch which
is a much easier thing to do than to try
to create a new behavior where none
existed before and we had to do that
because we had to get some quick wins
because my gaming project inside of
justin.tv would have been killed if it
wasn't showing 25 percent
month-over-month growth every single
month so we did and that meant focusing
on short-term get the people in right
now let's turned out to be good in
general because it turns out that
building something that some people want
generally generalizes and so I want to
bring in people who weren't even users
of the service as well yes
which has been around from the beginning
for a build-up for example the video
game industry in the beginning this
industry was very decentralized like
there wasn't a lot of cohesion like
different video game companies
consolidating where tournaments aren't
stuff but now it's very different so
originally spoke to like broadcasters
and you know strangers themselves how's
that changed when like for example like
riot as you know banned users yeah so
the question is what about the game
publisher it's basically right the game
publisher is these huge important people
in the space hey the game publishers and
any big company for that matter isn't
gonna give you the time of day as a
small start-up which is both good and
bad it means you don't really need need
to talk to them because they're they're
not interested in you but it means you
actually just can't talk to them I mean
we tried but no one wanted to talk to us
and they did once we started getting
some traction and and becoming a little
bit slightly bit of a player in the
space I don't like talk that bad about
them because I they they were nice about
enough about it it's just that you know
when you're when you're a tiny little
startup there's lots of tiny little
startups and they don't know the time to
talk to all of you as we've gotten
bigger actually the point that you know
game publishers have become an
increasingly important constituency for
us and if I was to talk about who twitch
does user interviews with now whoo-wee
whoo-wee pulled information from now it
would include game publishers definitely
because they've become a proactive in
the space it was something that they
weren't particularly active three or
four years ago as much as they are now
and that's another really important
point about user interviews in general
which is that the pool people you care
about is going to shift over time the
people who get you started look the
crucial people to get your product
started for the first six months or not
who will be using it three years later
and it's very important you keep doing
this stuff because one thing it's really
easy to do is do a little bit of it in
the beginning and and achieve some level
of success and then you're sort of
stopped talking to new people and that's
a good way to make the next set of
features you build be not as good as the
first ones yeah yes user feedback if
you're a user so how do you give good
user feedbacks really good question so I
I think
what I want a user to do is I want to
user to tell me about what they like
what they're really thinking right and
what what what their problems really are
and to just sort of ramble like I want
someone to like just tell me about stuff
in their life because the the more you
learn about them as a person and sort of
that the there what's going on in the
context of what they're doing the easier
just to understand why they want the
things they want and that's really the
critical question so I'd say like you
know what I'm looking for an A in
someone when I'm doing a user interview
if someone who's going to be willing to
talk a lot and be willing to really give
me a full give me a full picture so
that's what I guess on the flip side is
gonna be a good
you're gonna help people out with good
user interview feedback ramble like if
you just just talk about stuff and
everything alright great well thank you
very much
[Applause]
you